alors les gars si je me demande les
caisses grises en premier ça veut dire
on met les caisses grises au plus loin
pour pouvoir mettre le matos derrière
allez c'est pas parce qu'on est première
classe qu'on a pas un cerveau messieurs
pour pouvoir
[Musique]
les conflits actuels nous montrent que
ça existe encore
que ça soit là jusqu'à maintenant avec
les conflits un petit peu asymétriques
qu'on avait pu avoir que ça soit au
Sahel en Afghanistan ou justement les
zones refuge sont des zones de montagne
mais même actuellement avec le retour
des guerres symétriques donc les
conflits de haute intensité sur lesquels
on travaille actuellement on se rend
bien compte que justement il va falloir
tenir ces terrains tenir ses milieux
de 5 cartouches en appui sur tac fais
votre initiative
[Musique]
la principale difficulté ça va être de
gérer l'humain déjà donc de gérer
l'homme c'est à dire que si le soldat à
froid s'il commence à trembler forcément
ça va être beaucoup plus dur d'aligner
sentir et ça va être la gestion du
matériel on a très rapidement de la
neige qui va venir se mettre dans les
canons le pro le rend le métal qui est
cassant et on va avoir de l'armement qui
est vraiment soumis à rue des preuves et
c'est beaucoup plus dur de maintenir en
conditions après c'est avant 2h je
comptais les réveiller à minuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'à notre niveau en tout cas
ceux qui se sont engagés avant la guerre
en Ukraine justement le l'engagement
évolue pas forcément je pense que c'est
plutôt au niveau de la société qu'on se
rend compte aujourd'hui que les que
l'armée effectivement est indispensable
et que ce retour génère un stress
peut-être qu'on avait un petit peu
oublié mais pour nous finalement ça
change juste notre manière de nous
entraîner
face à un ennemi qui évolue et qui était
pas le même il y a 10 ans qu'il est
aujourd'hui
[Musique]